B salut Isabelle ça va ça va ouais ça va
alors grand panier ou petit panier des
denré de la ferme prennent place sur les
étales dans la MAP terrain vague huit
producteurs locaux proposent leur
marchandises en vente directe fruits
pain ou œuf issus de l'agriculture
biologique sont proposé chaque semaine
des colis gourmands récupérés par la
cinquantaine d'adhérents dans l'espace
Yv monant à Guille en cour on a des
produits très frais les légumes qu'on m
qu'on récolte le jeudi soir ils ont été
ramassés pour la plupart le jeudi matin
et on connaît aussi en quelque sorte
leur histoire on mange pas du poulet on
mange le poulet de Charles on mange pas
du fromage de chèvre on mange le fromage
de chèvre de Claudie une consommation
responsable loin de l'image de la grande
distribution dans cette Association pour
le Maintien d'une Agriculture paysane
pas de frais ni de tomates en hiver de
paniers hebdomadaires de 13 ou 22 €
doivent être récupérés chacun est
composé au rythme des saisons on se
laisse un peu surprendre parce que le
maréchf va nous proposer et ensuite bah
ça nous oblige à à cuisiner des légumes
qu'on avait peut-être pas le l'habitude
de cuisiner discussion sur les problèmes
de récolte ou les intempéries à travers
l'association une solidarité économique
se met en place pour soutenir les
agriculteurs chaque adhérant s'engage à
acheter à l'avance une partie de sa
récolte la garantie de revenus plus
pérenn moi les AMAP aujourd'hui à la
ferme ça représente 35 % de mes
débouchés je suis assuré sur ces 35 % ça
va me permettre de financer la
nourriture parce que 75 % de la
nourriture moi je la finance après la
moisson quoi donc j'ai un stock de
nourriture pour l'année grâce aux zap ça
va financer la nourriture de tous les
poulets quoi distribution des paniers ou
animation chaque membre doit donner de
son ans et s'acquitter d'une adhésion
annuelle de 15 € plus de 60 de ces
associations sont présente dans le
département des Yvelines de son côté la
map terrain vague à Guille en cours
faite cette année c'est 15